હ
[Musique]
autour du monde des hommes et des femmes
acheminent par bateau dé vivres à ceux
qui habitent au bord de
l'eau en Argentine Sébastian navigue
dans l'extraordinaire delta du Parana à
bord de son épicerie
flottante
en Thaïlande hty sillonne des centaines
de canaux dans sa minuscule barque
restaurant
elle se déplace de qu en qu pour offrir
à domicile les repas qu'elle cuisine à
bord deux histoires de cuisine de bateau
et de
voyage
situé à moins de 40 km au nord-ouest de
buenoser capitale de l'Argentine la
ville de tigre est surnommée la Venise
Argentine car c'est ici que se situe
l'immense delta du Parana plus de 3500
îles un labyrinthe de Canau et 4000
habitants qui ne se déplacent qu'en
bateau
[Musique]
kayak y scooter des mers ici tous les
types d'embarcation se
côtoi les emblématiques lancha bateauus
collectif en bois font la navette entre
la ville de tigre et les îes du
delta l'ignacio Franco le bateau
épicerie de Sébastian est amaré dans le
port de
de fois par semaine il part faire sa
tournée dans le
delta lundi matin
8h sastian et Franco son fils de 13 ans
non que 2 he pour charger les 35 tonnes
de
marchandis des fruits et légumes à la
viande en passant par les produits
d'entretien le bateau transporte tout ce
que l'on trouverait chez l'éper du
coin
bonjouruit à bord plus les ves sont
bonnes on vend combien un P
60 aujourd'hui on charge des
marchandises pour une tournée de 2 jours
autour de
l'Î ensuite on revient on recharge de
nouveau le bateau et cette fois-ci pour
une tournée de 3 jours
le temps presse sous peine d'amende
l'igncio Franco doit quitter le port à
10h plus tard d'autres bateaux attendent
leur tour pour
charger ça fait
4775 et l'utre
facture merci et bonne
chanceis le frère de sébasti a son
propre bateau chez
les FL est une affaire de
famille on aimait suivre notre père
quand on était
enfant à la fin de nos études on est
revenu pour travailler sur le bateau
mais notre père le sortait de moins en
moins
souvent alors on a eu nos propres
bateaux on a créé nos
épiceries et puis on a commencé à suivre
nos trajet
je passe par une branche de la rivière
et lui par l'autre on se sépare pour se
rendre dans des endroits
différents c'est comme ça qu'on gagne
notre vie chacun sur son bateau et
chacun de son
côté on est prêt on part dans quelques
minutes on charge le combustible et on y
va
les frères batinga démarrent leur
tournée pour
48h tout doit être impeccable le service
et la qualité des produits car la
concurrence est rude une dizaine
d'autres bateaux épiceries naviguent sur
les eaux brunes chargé d'alluvion du
majestueux
Delta
de l'autre côté du globe en Thaïlande la
région d'ampaa est situé à l'extrémité
nord-ouest de la baie de
Bangkok ici aussi des centaines de
canaux sentremell et servent encore
aujourd'hui de voie de communication de
transport et de
[Musique]
commerce des milliers de tailles vivent
le long des berges parmi eux
hty depuis 50 ans elle prépare tous les
matins ou presque une centaine de repas
qu'elle va charger dans sa minuscule
[Musique]
embarcation
le soleil n'est pas encore levé et déjà
s'active
elle commence à cuisiner les plats
qu'elle va livrer au fil des canaux dans
la
journée c'est le seul métier jamais
pratiqué j'ai commencé très
jeune en suivant ma mère sur les
canaux elle a vendu des repas dans cette
barque vie
alors vous voyez elle m'a transmis tout
son
savoir pour moi c'était évident de
reprendre la suite l'an prochain je
fitterai mes 70 ans je n'ai pris aucun
jour de congé depuis que j'ai commencé
ce métier à l'âge de 16
ans
dans sa préparation quotidienne elle
réserve toujours une part au moines qui
font l'omô de canal en
canal j'offre de la nourriture au moine
tous les
jours je le fais pour honorer la mémoire
de mes ancêtres
décédés on prépare des offrandes de
nourriture pour les moines qui viennent
nous voir en bateau depuis des centaines
d'années c'est la tradition ensuite il
récite une prière et nous offre leur
bénédiction le mari d' l'IDE du mieux
qu'il peut il a passé lui aussi une
grande partie de son existence sur l'eau
avant de perdre la
vue B chinois à fond
plat ce bateau est fabriqué en te un
maté souvent utilisé par les anciennes
génération c'est qu' pr pour fabriquer
le
bateau
la casserole d'uny est chauffée au
charbon le feu maintient le bouillon à
bonne température pendant tout le
trajet
il est 10h après 4 He de préparation hty
monte à bord de sa barque
cuisine soleil de plomb ou pluie
diluvienne peu importe elle est sur
l'eau tous les
[Musique]
jours
les centaines de canaux de la région
sont alimentés par le fleuve
meklong un cours d'eau de 132 km de long
qui se forme au confluent de la rivière
kille et se jette dans le golfe de la
[Musique]
Thaïlande ces canaux sont depuis
toujours empruntés par des commerçants
ou des propriétaires terriens qui ainsi
achemine fa le récolte vers les marchés
de la
région la construction de route n'a rien
changé les habitants restent attachés à
leur Canau et à leur
[Musique]
bateau je connais tous les canx de la
région peu importe où je vais je ne suis
jamais
perdu
avant il n'y avait pas de
route alors tous les déplacements se
faisai grâce à ces
canaux tout le monde util des
bateau c'était le seul moyen de
transport pour se rendre d'un point à
[Musique]
l'autre que tuux une soupe
des ensemble
[Musique]
oui il fait chaud c'est difficile pour
vous de rester à l'intérieur
aujourd'hui oui pendant la journée je ne
cuisine
[Musique]
pas
les clients connaissent bien le trajet
et les horaires
d'uny dès qu'ell se signal les clients
sortent avec leurs bol
ell sert tous les jours près de 80
repas pas plus cher qu'un plat fait
maison c'est donc une auè pour les
Rivin qu'est-ce que vous prenez je vais
prendre les nouilles avec la sauce rouge
je vous fais ça tout de suitepic s'il
vous plaît c'est combien de plus pour
les légumes c'est le même prix et pour
le grand bol je prends 20 BES pour le
bol de taille normale et pour le plus
grand c'est
35 merci c'est excellent ça fait plaisir
merci bon
appétit
[Musique]
tu es tout seul oui d'accord prends la
cuillère
qu'est-ce que je te sers des nouilles
Tom Yam s'il te
plaît parfait je te fais ça tout de
suite très épicé ou pas pardon très
épicé aujourd'hui par plus de 40 degr un
s'en relâche malgré le chaudron
bouillant quiugment encore la
température dans
l'embarcation 7 ans ne s'accorde aucune
pause je m'arrête jamais même pas pour
aller aux
toilettes je sais pas combien de
kilomètres je fais par jour sur mon
bateau mais je me doute que ça fait
beaucoup
[Musique]
est parfois la bonne fée de Marie etelé
qui n'ont jamais appris à
cuisiner j'avais hâte de manger des
nouilles ma femme n'est plus là et je ne
sais pas
[Musique]
cuisiner c'est pas facile
aujourd'hui tu tournes ici Leem plus
court tu vas te rendre jusque là-bas tu
veux dire faire
demi-tour tuiv le cour un moment pu le
remonter par
là-bas
[Musique]
il est 16h après 6h passé sur l'eau un
rentre chez elle avec en poche ses 20 €
[Musique]
quotidiens
chaque soir malgré la
fatigue accomplit le même rituel
elle remercie son bateau et l'eau des
canaux qui lui permett de gagner sa vie
elle est aujourd'hui la seule à faire
vivre son
couple
le bateau et les canaux sont très
importants dans ma
vie sans eux je ne peux pas
[Musique]
travailler retour dans le delta du
Parana en
Argentine tourné son bateau épicerie
navigue d'île en île certains clients
ont déjà passé commande par
[Musique]
téléphone du lait de l'eau minérale vous
m'avez dit quoi avant l'eau minérale la
livraison à domicile est très populaire
chez les iliens du delta mais elle a un
coup les prix sont entre 20 à 30 % plus
élevés qu'en
ville pour avoir les mêmes produits en
ville il faudrait prendre
B faire les courses attendre quelques
heures et revenir sur le prochain
bateau avec le prix du billet ça
reviendrait au même c'est donc
finalement plus économique et ça met
moins de
temps à plus tard allez on bouge merci
mon chéri bonne chance bonne
semaine on
Jeudi
Sébastian travaille avec Lise Jos qui
l'assiste pour toutes les tâches le
pilotage le service au client et
l'entretien du bateau au fil des années
l'employé est devenu comme un frère
ça fait 8 ans que Luis José travaille
avec
moi il est marin il pilote le bateau
pendant que je me
repose il s'occupe aussi de la
[Musique]
marchandise les séastian des natifs du
delta de riches habitants de buenoser en
vacances ou des touristes comme Julio
qui sont arrivés et ne sont plus jamais
repartis tiens les U fait pas une
tortill oh là faut que je fasse
attention ici ok on
socialise les relations sociales sont
très
importantes cette femme est une
espagnole de Barcelone celleel est catal
personne ne vient d'ici mais on vit tous
ici ah c'est
fait tu as besoin d'autre chose
oui la vie ici est liée de près à la
rivière je ne suis pas un expert mais je
constate que le mode de vie est liée à
la rivière et au coutumes c'est une
rivière vivante son niveau monte et
descend de manière impressionnante c'est
pourquoi les maisons sont
surpiloties il faut s'habituer à ce
style de
vie
du trava on AC beaucoup de marchand
danssour la maison qui est près d'ici au
milieu du bois après plus d'un mois à la
maison on ressent le bien d'
SAE et à
l'IS et nous on dit que c'est le bien d'
saucer parce qu'on trouve notre coin
[Musique]
magnifique les canaux du delta forment
une extraordinaire toile d'araignée les
centaines de rivières et de ruisseaux
sont alimentés par le fleuve Parana une
merveille naturelle de plus de 4000 km
qui s'écoule depuis les hauts plateaux
brésiliens
pour aller se jeter dans l'océan
Atlantique en
[Musique]
Argentine les canaux sont de véritables
routes navigables très fréquenté ici
tous les capitaines se
connaissent Sébastian est l'un des plus
connus quand le Ignacio Franco est dans
les parages de nombreux navigateurs en
[Musique]
profitent Pedro vient d'amarrer sa
chaloupe au bateau épicerie et vient
faire ses courses sans ralentir le
rythme de
croisière il vit au bord d'un ruisseau
où je ne peux pas passer et c'est pour
ça qu'il vient jusqu'à nous avec son
bateau
on a des articles à
vendre il ti un petit
magasin pass une bonne semaine
portez-vous
[Musique]
bien
le bateau épicerie fait une courte
escale chez et sa femme qui ont choisi
de passer leur retraite au cœur du
[Musique]
delta c'est paisible ici ce n'est pas
comme à la capitale c'est vraiment
paisible passer ces dernières années ici
pour les personnes âées c'est vraiment
très
bien
nous sommes venus ici parce que c'est
tranquille il y a la fille de ma
conjointe qui vit près
d'ici on a économisé de l'argent
plusieurs années pour bâtir cette maison
et maintenant elle est
terminée en réalité on a dû faire
beaucoup de
sacrifices on a dû se serrer la
ceinture on ne conna pas le prix d'une
maison achetée neuve il y a une maison
plus loin qui est à vendre ce moment
c'est 37900 € nous construisons la par
petit bout sur plusieurs années ça fait
5 ans que nous construisons notre
maison ici il y a moin d'occasion de
dépenser si nous étions en ville le
samedi le dimanche nous manger
restaurant et nous dépenser notre argent
à
l'extérieurci nous m sur
le
un autre client il y en a ici de l'autre
côté et ça
[Applaudissements]
continue Sébastian travaille souvent
avec son fils Franco qui prend son rôle
de moussaillon épicier très à cœur Ban
oui sal oui
biscuit biscuit de riz oui conserve de
thon oui citron oui tomate oui les tu
carottes les tu et carottes oui des ufs
attends pour les
carottes dès le début des vacances
scolaires Franco monte à bord du bateau
dès qu'il le pourra il prendra la relève
de son
père je suis en vacances scolair de
décembre à
mars aujourd'hui on a commencé le
travail à 4h du matin et on va terminer
vers 21h ou
22h qu'est-ce que tu aimes sur ce bateau
sur le bateau tout le paysage tout
conduire
aussi bien très
bien tuux
bi du matin au soir l'épicerie fluviale
s'arrête d'île en île sans interruption
dans ce décor naturel d'eau et de forêt
qui incite au repos l'équipage travaille
à un rythme
effrainé pas de pause déjeuner sur
l'igncio Franco pendant que le bateau
poursuit sa route on boit et on mange
comme et quand on
[Musique]
peut
le soleil se couche sur les canaux les
épiciers ambulants s'arrêtent enfin d
l'aube ils seront à nouveau sur le pont
[Musique]
retour dans la région d'ampawa en
Thaïlande la cuisinière ne montera pas à
bord de sa barque ce
matin aujourd'hui elle va faire des
courses au marché de Melong à une
demiheure de chez
elle
il est 6h du matin et j'attends
l'autobus pour aller au marché je vais
acheter tous les ingrédients dont j'ai
besoin pour cuisiner mes
[Musique]
nouilles
le marché de Melong est un endroit bien
connu en Thaïland car il est établi
autour d'une voie
[Musique]
ferrée
j'ai acheté des fèves germées des
nouilles du porc du poulet du canard du
tofou du poisson frit du liseron d'eau
de la coriand du Chili et de l' j'ai
dépensé environ 3000
battes de retour chez elle hty n'a pas
de temps à perdre avant de préparer ses
plats pour le lendemain elle doit
réparer sa
barque heureusement son fils lui donne
un petit coup de
main j'ai qu enfants mais je n'ai qu'un
seul
fils je m'appelle tatopon tamawad j'ai
37 ans et je suis sculpteur pour la
construction de
temple j' ma mère comme je peux en
préparant certains
ingrédients je fais frire le tofu et les
bâonnets de poisson ou encore je
confectionne le
sirop je ne vais pas vendre des repas
avec ma mère parce que je ne suis pas
très bon
làdedans aucun des enfants dy ne veut
suivre sa voie elle sera donc la
dernière de sa famille à cuisiner sur
l'eau je dois veiller à l'entretien du
bateau pour éviter qu' ne
s'habî si on oublie de mettre de
l'huile alors le bois va
pourir h prend grand soin de son bateau
qui a plus de 100 ans une barque
transmise de génération en génération
depuis ses arrières grands-parents
maternels je me sers de ce mélange pour
réparer les fissures sur le bateau si je
répare pas
il risque de
couler c'est une huile qu'on trouve dans
la région et que je mélange avec de la
poudre de
[Musique]
ciment une fois la coque réparé veille
aussi à la protection spirituelle de sa
barque à chaque voyage la cuisinière
emporte avec elle cette amulette qui
apporte sécurité et
[Musique]
abondance cette amulette m'a été donnée
par ma
mère c'est un porte-bonheur qui apporte
la
prospérité j'y ajoute des feuilles d'or
pour obtenir la bénédiction de la déesse
qui veille sur les
[Musique]
bateaux l'amulette reste dans mon bateau
tout le temps
[Musique]
demain sa journée sera particulièrement
chargée hunty va se rendre au plus grand
marché flottant de la région d'ampawa
c'est là qu'elle réalise ses meilleures
[Musique]
ventes alors que la journée d'uny
s'achève à l'autre bout de la planète en
Argentine Sébastian se réveille à peine
il est 6h du matin Sébastien et son fils
partent chercher le second José Louis
une nouvelle et longue journée commence
à bord du bateau
épicerie
j'ai réglé l'alarme de mon réveil à 5h
du
matin je me suis couché vers 1h30 cette
nuit ça veut dire que j'ai dormi une de
3h3 cette
nuit c'est facile de naviguer t le matin
parce que tout est calme ça devient plus
difficile en hiver lorsqu'il y a de la
brume mais l'été c'est facile de
naviguer c'est très beau la nuit
aussi ce matin le niveau de l'eau et eau
et rend la navigation
délicate Sébastian surveille les
courants et les variations de la
météo
aujourd'hui le niveau de l'eau est très
haut vent du sud-est qui amène toute
cette eau jusqu'ici ça pourevenir
dangereux le vent du Nord vient chercher
l'eau et du
sudestorte a beauucoup de vent le niveau
deeau pe monter jusqu'à 2 m c'est uneie
avec vent du sudest on c la monté de
l'eau
[Musique]
aujourd'hui la navigation ne semble pas
dangereuse mais elle peut rapidement le
devenir il y a quelques années le père
de Sébastian en a fait
l'expérience accident s'est déjà produit
il y a plusieurs années mon père
conduisait le bateau il y avait de la
brume et on est entré en collision avec
un autre bateau ça fait longtemps déjà
on a eu de la chance car il pas beaucoup
de dommage merci ça'est pas arrivé avec
mon
[Musique]
bateau
depuis l'âge de 6 ans Franco prend
parfois les commandes une sorte de
conduite accompagnée avant de passer le
permis
[Musique]
bateau co
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vos
gracias
[Musique]
sal merci nous prép quelque chose de
terrible la plie de l'eau beaucoup d'eau
on va se
[Musique]
reposerz réfrigérateur fonctionne AC
22 comm lesr appareils du bateau SAF le
moteur
propulseur au deè jour du voyage lis
José remplit la génératrice de gasoil
mesure de prévention pour que même en
cas de panne les aliments restent
frais on apporte toujours suffisamment
de carburant pour alimenter le
générateur tout au long du
trajet on Livi à cents et on en garde un
peu pour les autres appareils
[Musique]
àord
le Ignacio Franco n'est pas
l'embarcation habituelle de Sébastian le
véritable bateau épicerie est en
réparation je suisprpriétaire de ce
bateau avec mon be-père en réalité il
n'est pas du tout conçu pour servir de
bateau épicerie il est plutôt fait pour
transporter des Bill de bois nous
l'avons adapté temporairement pendant
que notre autre bateau est en
réparation on a travaillé pendant un an
et demi sur ce bateau mais on va bientôt
tout démonter pour y mettre une grue
afin de manipuler les
billot mon autre bateau est en cale
sèche depuis le mois d'aût de l'an
dernier ça fait déjà plus de 6 mois on
est peu à faire ce type de travail et ça
ne va pas en
s'améliorant acheter un bateau ça coûte
très cher et les réparations coûtent
cher aussi aujourd'hui je dirais que ce
bateau coûterait 98000
€ c'est
pourquoi tu en veux
combien c'est Gustavo le charpentier du
delta qui répare le bateau de
Sébastian il travaille seul et retape
deux embarcations en même
temps pour la coque de celui-ci le
sublime 3 il a prévu encore un an de
travaux
chat ces bateaux capablebl de
transporter de gros
chargements et doté d'un fond s'appelle
des
[Musique]
chatas il faut un cour d'eau d' moins 1
M50 à 2 m de profondeur pour naviguer
avec ce type de
bateau les rivières sont souvent base de
nos
jours et c'est ça qui avait brisé
l'arrière de ce bateau il n a pas de
drague dans le
delta
Sébastian a vendu une bonne partie de sa
marchandise il doit déjà penser à se
réapprovisionner pour sa prochaine
tournée l'heure est donc au commande
qu'il ira chercher à tigre plus tard
dans la
journée j'ai vendu 70% de tout ce qu'on
a
chargé c'est la proportion habituelle à
ce momentci de l'anne une grande des
habits de l enaiss le P au début du
moisoup plus
plus le MO avance plus les ventes
[Musique]
baissent après 48h de navigation dans le
delta l'IGN Franco est de retour à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tigre
[Musique]
l'équipage bien rodé organise les
opérations de
chargement à nouveau le temps est compté
la prochaine tournée dans le delta sera
plus longue il y a donc plus de
marchandises à embarquer près de 30000 €
de produits divers que le capitaine
épicier tentera d'écouler de son nouveau
[Musique]
voyage en Thaïlande hty s'apprête à
vivre une très longue journée de travail
elle part alors qu'il fait encore nuit
[Musique]
j'ai préparé des nouilles avec un
bouillon épicé et de la soupe tomyam
elle veut arriver tôt pour avoir le
meilleur emplacement sur le marché
flottant habituellement je me réveille à
3h là il est 6h et je charge le bateau
pour mon départ
[Musique]
je dois me lever tôt parce que je
vieillis je fais les choses beaucoup
plus lentement que lorsque j'étais plus
jeune il y a plusieurs années je pouvais
me lever à 4h et arriver à tout faire à
temps mais je ne vois plus très bien
alors ça me prend du temps pour tout
préparer
[Musique]
le marché flottant se trouve à une heure
de
navigation sur son chemin h croise déjà
des clients comme cette non qui vit dans
un temple non loin de
[Musique]
là
do faire
vite il faut arriver tôt au
marché dépcher parce que si je suis en
retard d'autres commerçants vont me
voler mes
[Musique]
clients
ce marché a plus de 100 ans il existait
déjà du temps de mes
grands-parents le marché a lieu une fois
par semaine mais à des dates différentes
il est calé sur le calendrier
[Musique]
lunaire ici au marché flottant seul des
femmes vendent des produits fruits
légumes fleurs un microcosme
féminin
[Musique]
il pas d'homme ici vous voyez
bien vendre de la nourriture sur un
bateau c'est un travail de femme les
hommes ils travaillent sur la terre
ferme toutes ces femmes sont mes amies
elles aiment bien venir ici pour se
rencontrer
[Musique]
se raconter des histoires
elle sch aussi de la nourriture
parfois pour ce lieu est l'endroit où
elle fait son meilleur chiffre
d'affaair ici toutes les femmes se
connaissent et s'entendent plus ou moins
bien avec leur bon et moins bon
côtéetteem toujours d'être affamé avant
d'acheter quelque
chose sur le marché flottant elles ne
sont que deux cuisinières la concurrente
d'uny s'appelle sambé elle a 72 ans les
deux femmes ne se fréquentent pas mais
se respecte elles savent qu'elles sont
les dernières à exercer ce métier dans
la région et que leur profession
disparaîtra avec
ell je fais ce métier depuis plus de 50
ans chacun fait ses petites affaires
je crois que c'est bientôt fini la jeune
génération n'est pas prête à faire
ça après l'heure du dîner l'activité du
marché flottant retombe et pour il est
temps de
rentrer c'était une bonne
[Musique]
journée j'ai gagné environ 1000 B
ça fait à peu près
50 boles de nouilles
vendu à thôi đm
[Musique]
T
en pagayant sur le chemin du retour un
reste coincé dans la végétation après
une longue journée de travail l'effort
pour se sortir de là de
trop il m'arrive souvent de rester
coincé dans la
végétation parfois ça peut me prendre
une demijournée pour me sortir de
[Musique]
là
avant les affaires étaient bonnes parce
que beaucoup de gens travaillaient sur
les
plantation j'avais beaucoup de
clients à cette époque les nouilles
étaient rares donc c'était un produit
spécial il y avait des jours où en deux
arrêts toute ma cargaison été
écoulé maintenant tout le monde peut en
acheter à l'épicerie du coin la
compétition est aussi devenue plus
féroce parce que les gens peuvent aller
manger au restaurant en y allant en
voiture mais quoi qu'il en
soit pourra à sonner les canaux à
nourrir les habitants isolés à pagayer
sous les arbres comme l'ont fait toutes
les femmes de sa
[Musique]
famille je n'aime pas les
voitures les bateaux sont plus
utiles m'enlever mon bateau ce serait
comme me couper les mains et les
jambes parce que je n'ai pas d'autres
moyen de gagner ma
vie
[Musique]
Sébastian et Anty chacun à leur manière
font vivre leur territoire ils suivent
le cours tranquille des canaux ou
s'aventurent dans les méandres des
fleuves et les courants des
deltas ils sont depuis la nuit des temps
la ligne de vie de ceux qui vivent au
cœur de la nature et de
l'eau
[Musique]
E